you still get out
yes sir
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
accompanied by medal of honor recipient
colonel ralph puckett jr united states
army
retired
[Music]
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen please join me as we mark this
very special occasion
in a word of prayer almighty god
the author of liberty our sustainer
protector and guide
hear our prayer and bless this ceremony
with your presence
as we honor colonel ralph plunkett jr a
courageous
warrior husband father and friend
who for 70 years has led the way from
his actions with the rangers on hill 205
while defending the freedom of the
people of korea
and throughout his life ralph has
continued to serve the army
and ranger regiment as an example of
leadership
of character and commitment for others
to follow
lord thank you for colonel puckett a
servant leader whose actions exemplify
the prestige
honor and highest free decor of the
ranger regiment
in the crucible of conflict he
selflessly put his comrades lives
before his own today as he accepts our
nation's highest military honor for
value
may his words of encouragement spoken to
many over the years continue to ring
true
be proud but never satisfied
bless ralph his loving and devoted wife
of 68 years gene family fellow rangers
comrades and others today in spirit
lord let ralph's life legacy in this
very metal
that is placed around his neck inspire
us all in challenging times
to lead the way we thank you for the
blessings of freedom
and those who serve to preserve and
defend it it is in your majestic and
mighty name i pray
amen
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the white house
president moon it's a real honor to have
you here participating in this ceremony
today
the strength of the alliance between the
united states the republic of korea was
born
out of the courage determination
sacrifice and
of the korean troops fighting shoulder
to shoulder with american troops
and having you here today is an
important recognition of
all that our nation has achieved
together both of them
in the decades since and i'm joined by
my wife jill who's as excited about this
event as i
am the vice president and the second
gentleman are here as well
our secretary of defense vice chairman
of the joint chiefs of staff the
officials of the united states army
as well as several members of congress
representatives ferguson
representative crowe and senator ernst
because today we are hosting a true
american hero and awarding an honor
that is long overdue more than
70 years overdue 70 years ago on a
frozen hilltop
deep in what is now north korea a young
first lieutenant
bravely out of westby point and barely
out of west point
acted with bravery and that earned him
the distinguished service cross
the military's second highest honor
today after more than a decade of effort
including support from my good friend
john mccain god rest his soul shortly
before he passed away
i'm incredibly proud to give colonel
ralph
puckett's act of valor the full
recognition
they have always deserved colonel
i'm humbled to have you here today i
really am along with your loving family
and to award you the medal of honor
and though i understand that your first
response
to us hosting this event was to ask
why all the fuss why all the fuss
can't they just mail it to me
i was gonna make a joke about the post
office but i decided not to do that
colonel puckett after 70 years
rather than mail it to you i would have
walked it to you you know your lifetime
of service to our nation
as i think deserves a little bit of fuss
a little bit of fuss you know when i
called to tell the colonel that i had
approved this award
i also spoke to uh genie excuse me for
using your first name but
that was my mom's name too and you're my
mom of the same eyes although you're
much
too young to be my mom and uh
they've been married for 68 years we
have something else
we have one thing in common we both
married way up
we both married way up
that's exactly right well janie and
ralph actually
met while he was recovering from his
wounds
they were married two years to the day
after the battle that we're recognizing
him today for his bravery
by the way you all can sit down i think
it just dawned on me i understand why
you're standing i'd be standing too but
but
genie it's wonderful to welcome you i
mean that from the bottom of my heart
jill and i know firsthand that it's not
just the person who wears the uniform
who serves
military families make enormous
sacrifices
for our nation so let me add our thanks
to you
and your life of service as well i told
you earlier that expression by the poet
they also stand only
they also serve only stand and wait and
you've waited a long long time under
many
many many circumstances and that goes to
the entire family
marty and her husband anthony uh thomas
and
partner chip i don't know if they're
here i didn't see them yet
and i know the other daughter that
jeannie isn't with us anymore
just like i wish our son beau were able
to be here to see this
he's not with us either she's sharing
spirit and represented by her family and
i know she's always in your heart
colonel
and never leaves i also want to
recognize master
sergeant merle simpson who fought beside
the colonel in korea where are you
stand up sir
[Applause]
who made the trip to washington today to
represent all
of their fallen brothers from the 8th
army ranger company
it's an honor it's an honor for all
their members as well
hill 205 was just 60 miles from the
border with china
and then lieutenant bucket and the
rangers
had their orders to take that hill as a
young
officer with ten of puckett knew that
something wasn't quite right
the intelligence briefing indicated that
there were 25
000 chinese troops in the area
outnumbering u.s and korean forces
two to three i should be three to two
lieutenant puckett though the numbers
thought the numbers for the attack
didn't align with the basic military
doctrine lieutenant
believed in the fundamentals it was how
he trained
his men and how he'd hand-picked them
chosen from the ranks of cooks and
clerks and mechanics
to uh the first ranger company since
world war
ii physical conditioning tactical
training
working as a team get the basics right
then bill from there lieutenant puckett
also believed in being there for the
fight
he volunteered for the army corps
enlisted reserve
to try to join uh uh to fight in world
war ii
he volunteered to go to korea and
instead
of the safer posting in japan he
volunteered for the new ranger company
and then he prayed dear god
don't let me get a bunch of guys good
guys killed
when he was chosen to command that
company
so on the morning of november 25th
1950 mounted on the decks of the tanks
51 of puckett's rangers and nine korean
enlisted soldiers set out to take hill
205.
to make their charge they had to cross
about a half a mile of frozen rice
paddies under fire
and when the anti-machine gunners slowed
the rangers advance
puckett risked his life by running
across the area to draw a fire
that would reveal with the location of
the nest
he did it once he did it again it took
three runs
intentionally exposing himself to the
enemy to pick off the gunner
of course colonel puckett had developed
a dangerous hobby as he recounted in his
book of
challenging himself to run in front of
speeding cars when he was four years old
so self-preservation it seemed was never
a primary concern
of the colonel when the rangers finally
reached the top of hill 205
they found it abandoned but puckett knew
the fight wasn't nearly over
his men established a defensive
perimeter and then went to coordinate
the artillery support
he was sure they would need and
while he was there to load up the
ammunition
on ammunition and grenades the basics
shortly after return the first onslaught
began
mortars followed by a ground assault
from the entire
chinese battalion puckett's rangers were
outnumbered almost ten to one
during the fight puckered uh abandoned
the relative safety of his foxhole
moving from man to man encouraged them
in the fight
checking that the perimeter was holding
he took a grenade fragment in his left
thigh
but puckett refused to be evacuated he
was a ranger
he led his men from the front and over
the course of the next several hours
four more ways of assaults came each
time
puckett made his rounds passing out
extra ammo and extra encouragement to
rally his men
each time he was able to call in
artillery support
sometimes danger close to help break the
advance of the chinese soldiers
in each time the rangers held a hill
pushing nanny back at times with
hand-to-hand fighting
about 2 30 a.m after more than four
hours of near non-stop fighting
the sixth wave began by this time
the rangers had many rangers had been
killed
and those who were left were exhausted
outnumbered and dangerously assured
dangerously short of ammunition and
grenades
lieutenant puckett had sustained a
second moon
this time in his left shoulder he had
distributed all the ammo to his men
keeping only eight bullets and a bayonet
for himself
for the last time puckett called in
artillery support
only to be told that the guns were
supporting other besieged units
then two mortar rounds landed directly
in puckett's foxhole
tearing through both his feet and his
backside and his left arm and shoulder
puckets rangers had been overwhelmed and
he himself was badly wounded
he ordered one of his men to find him on
the ground
to leave him behind but that's not the
ranger creed
the private ran for help and soon
two other rangers charged back up the
hill fighting off advancing chinese
soldiers
retrieving their commander they had the
dragon down the hill
with lieutenant puckett reminding them
and himself
that he could take the pain quote i'm a
ranger
before his men loaded him in on a tank
to evacuate the tenant bucket call for
one final barrage on hill 205
and the eighth army unloaded artillery
while phosphorus on the rangers form of
and
phosphate phosphorus on the range's
former position
they did not hold the hill but the
rangers extracted a high price
korean is sometimes called the forgotten
war
but those men who were there under
lieutenant puckett's command
they'll never forget his bravery they
never forget
that he was right by their side
throughout
every minute of it and the people of the
republic korea haven't forgotten is
evidenced by the fact
that the prime minister of korea is here
for this ceremony i doubt
this has ever happened before i can't
say that for certain but i doubt it's
happened before
the americans all americans like ralph
puckett
joined in their fight and while the
enduring partnership here
between our two nations began the war it
has flourished through peace
it's the uh it's testament i think of
the extraordinary strength of our
alliance
and uh we're joined today as i said by
president moon but i can't tell you how
happy i am he's able to be here
and if i may i'd like to invite
president moon to say a few words
if that is okay president moon
mr president thank you for your awards i
find it truly meaningful to join the
medal of honor presentation ceremony for
colonel ralph
puckett jr u.s army retired upon
president biden's invitation
i learned that i'm the first foreign
leader to ever attend the ceremony of
such kind
as president of the republic of korea it
is a great honor and pleasure
is a true hero of the korean war with
extraordinary valor and leadership he
completed missions
till the very end defending hill 205 and
fighting many more battles requiring
equal valiance without the sacrifice of
veterans including cardinal puckett and
the 8th army range company
freedom and democracy we enjoyed today
couldn't have blossomed in korea
told me that when he was in korea during
the korean war
it was absolutely destroyed that was
true but from the ashes of the korean
war we rose
we came back and that was thanks to the
korean war veterans who fought for
korea's
peace and freedom and now thanks to
their
support and efforts we are enjoying
prosperity
foreign
on behalf of the korean people i
expressed deep gratitude and respect to
them
through the war veterans the korean
people saw a great soul of america that
marches toward freedom and peace
their acts of gallantry sacrifice and
friendship will forever
be remembered
right
forces and blood of heroes has become a
linchpin of peace and prosperity on the
korean peninsula and beyond
karna pakket and his fellow warriors are
a link that strongly binds korea and the
u.s together
i pray that they stay with us in good
health for a long time thank you very
much
well thank you president moon now i'd be
remiss
if i didn't note that ralph puckett's
service to our nation
did not end in the korean war
it did not end after his service in the
vietnam war
where he earned a second distinguished
service cross
two silver stars two brown stars with v
for valor and add to that during his
service
five purple hearts for injuries suffered
in combat
and it didn't end after his retirement
from active duty or his induction into
the uh
ranger hall of fame it didn't end there
either
when he served as the honorary colonel
for the 75th ranger regiment
where he'd help new generation of
rangers during their training missions
even now even now you can find him out
at fort benning
cheering on the rangers and letting them
know
he's there with him over his career
he mentored countless young people he's
always believed
that all that mattered to be a ranger
was he had the guts and the brains that
the standard he applied when he picked
his first
ranger unit in korea in an army that
only recently been
integrated he chose with his team
included
a black a latino and asian american
members
my mother would say god love you man
in 2015 during the obama bible
administration
and the military is considering open all
combat positions to women
including rangers colonel puckett
let it be known that he thought women
could meet the standards and said
i want to see them do it
he leads from the front he leads by
example
he leads with his heart he's a ranger
and that's how rangers lead that's how
you lead
so now it is my great honor
to ask for the citation to be read and
to award
colonel puckett jr ralph puckett jr with
the medal of honor
the president of the united states of
america authorized by act of congress
march 3rd 1863 has awarded in the name
of congress
the medal of honor to first lieutenant
ralph puckett jr
united states army for conspicuous
gallantry and intrepidity at the risk of
his life
above and beyond the call of duty first
lieutenant ralph puckett jr
distinguished himself by
acts of gallantry and intrepidity above
and beyond the call of duty while
serving as the commander
8th u.s army ranger company during the
period of 25 november
1950 through 26 november 1950
in korea as his unit commenced a
daylight attack on hill 205
the enemy directed mortar machine gun
and small arms fire against the
advancing force
to obtain fire first lieutenant puckett
mounted the closest tank
exposing himself to the deadly enemy
fire
leaping from the tank he shouted words
of encouragement to his men and began to
lead the rangers in the attack
almost immediately enemy fire threatened
the success of the attack
by pinning down one platoon leaving the
safety of his position
with full knowledge of the danger froze
lieutenant puckett intentionally ran
across an open area
three times to draw enemy fire thereby
allowing the rangers to locate and
destroy the enemy positions
and to seize hill 205.
during the night the enemy launched a
counter-attack that lasted four hours
over the course of the counter-attack
the rangers were inspired and motivated
by the extraordinary leadership and
courageous example
exhibited by first lieutenant puckett as
a result
five human wave attacks by a battalion
strength enemy enemy element were
repulsed
during the first attack first lieutenant
puckett was wounded by grenade fragments
but refused evacuation and continually
directed artillery support
the decimated attacking enemy formations
he repeatedly abandoned positions of
relative safety to make his way from
foxhole
to foxhole to check the company's
perimeter and to distribute ammunition
amongst the rangers
when the enemy launched a sixth attack
it became clear to first lieutenant
puckett
that the position was untenable due to
the unavailability
of supporting artillery fire during this
attack
two enemy mortar rounds landed in his
foxhole inflicting grievous wounds which
limited his mobility
knowing his men were in a precarious
situation first lieutenant puckett
commanded the rangers to leave him
behind and evacuate the area
feeling a sense of duty to aid him the
rangers refused the order
and staged an effort to retrieve him
from the foxhole while still under fire
from the enemy
ultimately the rangers succeeded in
retrieving first lieutenant pocket
and they moved to the bottom of the hill
where first lieutenant
first lieutenant puckett called for
devastating artillery fire on the top of
the enemy controlled hill
first lieutenant pockets extraordinary
heroism and selflessness
above and beyond the call of duty we're
in keeping with the highest traditions
of military service
and reflect great credit upon himself
his unit
and the united states army
[Applause]
let me invite the family up come on get
the family up here
all of you including the kids
hey
and the second left
mr president would you mind standing
here too
is that okay
all right
[Applause]
oh
okay
they could
[Music]
thank you
ladies and gentlemen please join me as
we conclude today's ceremony of walker
carl walken you may be 94
but i see the same grip and
determination of a young lieutenant
in your body of messenger please join me
in a word of prayer
most holy god as we leave this ceremony
inspire and encourage us to greater acts
of service to our nation and army's
people
give us the fortitude to always give a
hundred percent and then some
may you bless colonel ralph puckett jr
as he joins the pantheon of heroes
who have distinguished themselves
through selfless acts of bravery
may his leadership and legacy be a
waypoint for us to follow
keep us all strong in spirit and give
our leaders wisdom as they serve our
nation's people
bless and protect our armed forces as
they preserve our precious freedoms
keep the lamp of liberty burning bright
on the united states of america
our allies around the world as well i
ask these things in your most blessed
and holy name
amen
president
[Laughter]
and agreed with secretary of defense
[Laughter]
oh
come on get that picture
[Applause]
maybe if there's time you should walk
out that
maybe the generals may come back and say
hi
all right
okay
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay all right
oh
[Music]
down here
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yes